they've been building the barricades
across Venezuela for days now tempers
flare as people realize they won't be
able to move around anymore the protests
against the government's been going on
for months but it's certainly growing
across the capital Caracas fires burned
as people prepare for confrontation with
the government over its plans to rewrite
the Constitution it doesn't matter where
you go and who you speak to the young
and old the armed and unarmed they're
all resolute that change must come
without it violence they say is
inevitable he's going to be ok because
kind of radio we have right here the
Human Rights prophetic rights everything
so we can allow that and you think I
thought there will be civil war you know
he'll you much of the city has been
brought to a standstill by the
confrontation with the government Armed
Forces the only way we could get around
and through the barricade was on
motorbikes crisscrossing the capital for
the past few days and soon became clear
that this is a city and a country in
turmoil but these streets should
normally be absolutely
with traffic and with people there are a
few people and milling around but
actually it's pretty much sealed off all
these roads on either side have got
barricades across them so there's no
traffic able to get here the expectation
is that later the day the chopper will
start
the anti-government movement involves
people from all walks of life including
its pin-up girl
Katerina Cyr soluti they call her Wonder
Woman
after these pictures were flashed across
the world
we joined her on the barricade
I asked if changing the government was
as much a fantasy as the Wonder Woman
character herself it's real totally real
and we're going to make it of course
we're going to have another Venezuela
that is well it's already done yeah
the political chaos here is only
overshadowed by the economic disaster
Venezuela is now a country of queues
there are shortages of everything from
money to food and basic living
essentials on street corners people
rummage through rubbish eating what they
can find these men aren't down-and-outs
they're just starving the problems
really hit home in hospitals though we
film undercover 83% of the patients here
have malnutrition little girl sits while
her exhausted mother slump beside her
there is simply nothing for them in
places it's filthy floors are cleaned
without detergent virtually no machines
work there are no drugs a hospital for
1200 can't cope with 300 what is a year
since we were last here it was pretty
bad then now it's a quite unbelievable
there is nothing
no drugs patients come here to be looked
after as opposed to being treated it is
an absolute international condemnation
of the government's plans to create a
one-party state have been ignored how
long the president can ignore his own
people probably depends on the support
of the armed forces despite all their
efforts the opposition hasn't been
crushed and hasn't been silenced still
Ramsey Sky News Caracas